bonjour suite de ce championnat du monde
2016 entre donc magnus carsen le tenant
du titre et sergueï kaliakine son
challenger nous sommes maintenant dans
les tie break après ses 12 premières
parties où les adversaires n'ont pas
réussi à se départager
on l'a vu qu arsène a eu chaud quand
même dans la 8ème carla qui n'a repris
l'aventage mais il a réussi qu'à carsen
à revenir très rapidement dans la 10e et
s'est contenté du nul rapide avec les
blancs d'ailleurs dans la deuxième peu
importe nous avons maintenant les
tie-breaks ça va se décider donc quatre
parties rapides et puis en cas d'égalité
cette fois les blitz alors déjà les
parties rapides ça peut se décider là
bien entendu première de ses quatre
parties de ce mini matchs et en rapide
donc pour les départager
cariat qui n'allait blanc c'est parti et
voilà que quatre ça ne change pas eu 5
qui arrive trois câbles c6 donc c'est la
même toujours très certainement une
espagnole luis lopez grandes variantes
classique fou bessin je reviens pas
dessus on a vu ça
maintes fois dans le match à 6 voilà que
la carcel ne varie pas un trou sa
première fois d'ailleurs qui fait ça un
championnat du monde parce que
d'habitude il variait beaucoup
ces ouvertures et là vraiment il a
choisi de suivre une ligne quasiment
tout le temps ce qui ce qui ne lui
ressemble pas par rapport à ce qu'on
connaissait de lui voilà x 4 qui arrive
si ce petit rock fawcett détroit voilà
la variante un peu moderne a ajouté
trois ans on cherche pas à pousser des
cas trop vite on on laisse les noirs
roquet des six tours où on peut jouer
après ces trois ans que je me foutais 3
à 3,6 cafétéria qui donc c'est du rapide
du reuz je ne commande pas trop four b3
on va regarder juste les points chauds
des 6 à 3 voilà alors ça cas qui nous a
montré ça plusieurs fois
donc au lieu du plan c 3 pouces et 2 qui
est lent à troyes et amiens four à deux
on laisse le faut sur ces diagonales une
idée du rock
halak a laissé 3 1 kb8 heures ça c'est
un peu un peu nouveau je crois que
personne n'avait pas vraiment joué ça
précédemment on veut jouer ces cinq vite
et replacer le cavaly sans doute au 17
et au lieu de jouer cavalier à 5,6 si on
avait voulu remettre en tapant si on
voulait jouer ces scènes qui remettent
le carillon c6
autant je vous car il ya cinq dans ce
cas là on est obligé de jouer en justice
m et après on reviendra ici
mais si on joue en vie c'est sans doute
convenir en dix-sept voilà on peut le
déduire logiquement cavalia 2 c5 et
carys g3 voilà très rapidement le
cavalier au lieu de passer par des deux
f1 g3 qui oblige à bouger la tour et
tous ont fait qu'ali ces trois cas les
deux cavaliers 3 et on allait les fameux
le fameux duo de cavaliers là qui est
prêt à beaucoup de variantes arts à se
lancer à l'assaut du roi noir avec une
fougue qui contrôlent une grande et
bonne à l'itie donc c'est une partie où
les blancs peuvent monter une attaque
real est le roi il revient quand même en
c6 voilà on aurait pu faire la veille à
5 et qui fait quand même classé 6 mhz
ces trois tombes et 8 h 3 à 5 à 4 on
essaie de perturber un petit chêne
depuis on a filmé la classe b 5 si les
noirs prennent on peut reprendre du fou
ou de la tour et si les noirs poussé ben
ali à la casse des scènes qui est un peu
faible ça peut aider plus tard voilà c3i
pousse aussi la fameuse on l'a déjà vu
plusieurs fois la possibilité pour les
blancs de prades avec un pion doublé
mais on l'a vu aussi savourer la colonne
f avec des possibilités d'attaqué donc
contre chance aussi poussé quatre ça
c'est original
on n'avait pas vu précédemment on joue
le français car si on laisse les noirs
prendre même en c4 on sort un pion du
centre ce qui n'est pas habituel et
seulement contre intuitif ce qu'on
enlève un pion du centre mais on ouvre
la colonne des et puis on verrouille
complètement la casse des 5 et la casse
des quatre les pions doublé là en fait
contrôler toutes les cases d'invasion
des noirs et l'idée c'est sans doute de
faire une pression sur des cinq et on
peut on pourra mettre un cavalier des
scènes plus tard calais funk l'e3 qu'il
ya des scènes par exemple est
envisageable
donc ainsi si le nord ne prennent pas
faux trois lanceurs le fou ici un petit
oeil sur la case des 4 to cd4
certainement pouvoir reprendre plus tard
du fou si on a besoin d'hommes c8
attention dame s'est vite et bien ça
menacerait du tout
c'est un bon petit oeil quand même ici
faut faire attention on sait jamais bon
a priori il ya quand même pas mal de
pièces ça m'étonnerait qu'ils puissent
compter qu que ce soit c'est sans doute
ce soit sur tout simplement pour
reprendre de la dame alors pourquoi pas
d'âme 17 mai pour pas laisser la dame
sur la colonne des on veut mettre une
tour nm2 voilà tour des huit la foudre a
et donc si on prend voilà c'est pour ça
qu est-ce qui sait le fellah dhabi si je
sais pas donc puis on prend mais bon là
sa championne du monde et moi je peux
pas je peux pas tout expliquer c'est pas
possible
d4 et là ça va simplifier après des
quatre voilà alors des cas tout de suite
mais les prix ont doublé on voit que
voilà ils sont d'un très très solide et
dès qu'on pousse mais on peut dédoubler
les pions ou très rapidement on y
apprend d'abord en c3 crise prises et
ensuite il prend des 4 et enfin voilà
c'est fini
il ya plus que doublé alors le seul
petit désavantage morand microscopique
des noirs effectivement ils ont trois
îlots de pions contre de ces trois
cibles les pions qui sont comme ça qui
peut pas se protéger les îlots ce duo ne
protège pas celui là voilà donc on peut
les attaquer à des pièces il faut les
défendre avec des pièces bon mais
maintenant c'est pas facile d'aller
attaquer comme lorsqu'on entre d'actifs
qu'avaient les prendre il simplifie au
maximum fou prend peut pas dire qu'ils
aient vraiment des problèmes s'il faut
faire attention mais sûre quand même
quitte avantages de la rend à cause de
ces si vos pions quand même rodez en
face ici c'est ses propres vingt deux
îlots simplement des positions n'ont ils
pas facile d'aller trouver des
faiblesses attaquer quand même tour b4
intéressant petite pression ici petite
pression à travers l'île pour le pjak a
très bien défendu mais attaque le fou
attaque un petit peu le pion c4 aussi
pour celle attaque la dame d'amd cette
attention attaque bien sûr que quatre
comprimés les blancs ici vous c3a il va
y avoir des échanges tout reprend et la
regarder si vous reprenez d'emprunt et
le pion à cinq et ils pouvaient pas le
reprendre
alors qu'en fait quand vous avez ça
regarde bien la tour par transparence
protège à 5
c'est ça qu'il faut piger dans ce type
de couvrir des frappes
voilà on peut prendre pas de problème
parce que si tous reprendront tour prend
là bizarrement alors on a l'impression
que le fouet pour protéger mais en fait
s'il l'est par transparence
voilà
à noter que si les noirs double les
tours ce qui est possible et bien on
arrive le fou en protégeant la torah
donc prise prise prise fou prend à la
fin et c'est bon ils rien donc les
blancs ont échangé les deux pions de
l'ale ce qui les arrange pas parce que
du coup les pions ici sont toujours un
peu isolé mais ils sont tellement
proches que le roi en venant rêve set
par un contrôle voilà qui contrôle les
deux îlots donc ça s'arrange pas les
blancs d'avoir fait cet échange ce n'est
pas une bonne affaire pour prendre tôt
ra8 voilà à bombay
attention ça cloue un petit peu le
foulard faut faire attention donc voilà
les blancs sort tout de suite du clonage
pour prendre fou prend bon voilà la
partie quasiment fini alors à bon
escient
c'est un petit peu faible si on veut ici
d'accord mais bon on n'a même pas le
foot cases blanches auxerre que la sueur
cases noires en tout est verrouillé là
tout est vite tout est bien solide bon
un petit classe danger si ce qu on
pourrait aller peut-être c'est très
difficile d'envisager de quoi que ce
soit dams et si son actif simplement la
dame que les glaires elle menace même si
un échec qui te haïssent euro iv aussi
au passage leur watch de l'échec
bref cette voilà ce que je disais
n'auront à peu venir contrôler les deux
îlots voilà donc ils sont isolés mais
pas loin donc on peut quand même voilà
avec une pièce comme le roi protéger les
deux fauves et deux dames c5f 4
fodé vite c'est du rapide donc je vais
pas trop dans les détails parce que
évidemment les joueurs avec vingt dix
minutes et plus j'ai patienté 5 secondes
par contre en seconde et 5 rebonds et 5
prises évidemment fou prend fou b6
attention mon asmat quand même à une
menace pas facile pas difficile à part
et voilà d'âme des uns terminé à peindre
c'est fini
dans des 5 et enfin ici les blancs
échange les dames et après cavale et
prend les noirs et les blancs qu'on
vienne de là nul ici dans cette première
partie les blancs pas réussi à obtenir
grand chose de ce début c'est quand même
curieux que kara qui n'insiste alors
qu'il obtient rien et si de pas varié
bon c'est pas la première fois il
obtient rien à cette variante mais bon
tant pis voilà donc terminé pour ce pour
ce premier première partie du tie-break
parties nulles un peu dans la lignée du
match même variante même résultat a donc
à tout de suite pour la prochaine vidéo
on verra donc la deuxième partie de ce
tie break elle qui va être champion du
monde est ce que car ses moeurs des son
titre ou kayak in deviendra-t-il le 17e
a tout de suite